[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce 78 actu en
ce mercredi 19 février nous allons
démarrer par une image celle d'Eva
linora la finale régionale du 40e
championnat de France de dessert bien de
révéler ses gagnants et bien dans la
catégorie professionnelle c'est donc
elle Eva linora de la maison le nôre
plaisir qui remporte les votes du jury
grâce à son dessert que vous découvrez
fraîcheur givré d'agrume et d'exotisme
tout un programme EV linora qui va
maintenant concourir pour la grande
finale nationale qui aura lieu les 25 et
26 mars prochain à Nice je rappelle que
ce championnat a été créé il y a 40 ans
à l'initiative du Centre d'études et de
documentation du sucre on va tout à fait
changer de sujet avec mon invitéti anim
bonsoir vous êtes chargé de mission à la
prospective auprès de la présidence de
l'université versaill Saint-Quentin vous
êtes également maître de conférence en
en histoire et puis aussi membre élu du
conseil scientifique de l'UVSQ et si
vous êtes en plateau avec nous ce soir
c'est pour nous apporter un éclairage
sur la situation du VSQ dont on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il y a un déficit de 5,2
millions d'euros alors qui représente
entre 3 et 4 % du du budget à deux
reprises au mois de janvier au mois de
février l'université a présenté un
budget qui était en déséquilibre ce qui
est pas conforme et donc ça a été
retoqué par le rectorat euh aujourd'hui
le 1er mars il y aura finalement un
budget ça on est sûr qu'il y aura un
budget au 1er mars mais de quoi sera
composé son ce budget à la fois on parle
de d'aide exceptionnelle de de l'État
d'aide remboursable he je précise et
puis d'économie encore à faire alors
déjà est-ce que vous avez des
informations de la part du ministère à
savoir sur ces 5,2 millions d'euros qui
manque combien l'État est prêt à
s'engager sur combien combien il va
falloir encore faire de d'économie alors
pour l'instant non parce que les
discussions sont toujours en cours les
discussions sont toujours en cours et
euh nous avons actuellement à travailler
avec les équipes du ministère avec les
équipes du rectorat pour affiner les
projets de budget c'està qu'il faut
expliquer que effectivement vous l'avez
dit il y a une difficulté financière sur
3 à 4 % de la masse globale du budget on
est sur un budget annuel pour une
université comme la nôtre de30 à 140
millions d'euros donc 95 % 96 97 % du
budget est arrêté don on voit ces
grandes lignes en revanche il y a une
difficulté sur la la le financement de
la la part restante et cette difficulté
d'autant plus grande en début d'année
que on n pas encore tout à fait fini la
clôture de l'année comptable 2013 que
donc on ne sait pas exactement quel est
le niveau de ce qu'on appelle le fond de
roulement c'est-à-dire l'argent qui
reste à l'université donc l'aide
exceptionnelle et remboursable que le
ministère pourrait nous apportter sera
fixé aussi à mesure qu'on aura affiné
tous ces indicateurs et qu'on aura une
exê fixé au 1er mars ou pas normalement
au 1er mars effectivement on peut tabler
sur un budget qui sera réalisable par
ailleurs il faut rappeler aussi que ce
ce qu'on établit comme budget
normalement en janvier en février là
peut-être en mars c'est ce qu'on appelle
un budget primitif c'est-à-dire que
c'est les lignes de dépense de ce qu'on
va réaliser pendant l'année c'est un
outil de travail c'est-à-dire que on
peut travailler avec un budget dont on
sait qu'il va fluctuer pendant l'année
en fonction des recettes en fonction des
dépenses du nombre d'inscrits en septre
mais malgré tout au 1er mars ça veut
dire que si l' si l'état donc vous êtes
sûr en tout cas qu'elle vous accordera
une aide remboursable mais a priori
c'est l'engagement du ministère
aujourd'hui il y aura peut-être des
économies encore à faire est-ce qu'on
peut encore réaliser des économies qui
ont déjà été faites précédemment alors
l'université a déjà fait un très gros
effort d'économie et a essayé de trouver
de l'argent là où il était possible d'en
trouver ensuite il y a des postes il y a
des fonctions sur lesquels il n'est pas
possible d'économiser simplement parce
que c'est le fonctionnement quotidien de
l'université qui est en en cause donc
nous sommes en train de réfléchir à la
manière dont en particulier à la rentrée
prochaine on pourra prolonger les
économie c'est par exemple le cas avec
la masse salariale il faut savoir que
dans une université 70 à 80 % du budget
c'est la masse salariale le salaire des
gens donc ça veut dire que si on
continue à faire ce qu'on fait
actuellement c'est-à-dire ne pas
remplacer les gens qui partent et bien
on économise leur salaire et donc petit
à petit on comble les trous donc
effectivement pour l'instant pas de
remplacement de de gens qui partent à la
retraite par exle voilà les gens qui
partent à la retraite les gens qui sont
en mutation dans d'autres universités
actuellement leurs emplois sont gelés
c'est-àdire que les emplois ne
disparaissent pas mais l'argent qui sera
utilisé à payer leur remplaçant est Act
actuellement utilisé pour financer notre
déficit mais ça a une limite
c'est-à-dire que il y a un moment donné
où au-delà de quelques dizaines
d'emplois gelés l'université ne peut
plus fonctionner alors quand on entend
les syndicats que soit des syndicat de
personnel ou d'étudiants ils ont
manifesté notamment devant le le siège
de l'université à l'occasion des
différents conseils d'administration
l'UNEF qui envisage encore un
rassemblement il y a une inquiétude de
ce côté-là qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez quel est l'état réel de
l'université aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire les salaires sont versés les
cours continuent siz par qu'on a
l'impression que voilà par les syndicats
sont dans leur rôle de syndicat et c'est
parfaitement normal ils sont représentés
dans les conseils les actions qu'ils ont
pu mener sont des actions syndicales
légitimes et ils les ont également mené
ils ont porté leur message dans le cadre
des
conseils il est normal que les gens
soient inquiets quand on a
des une situation de déficit de ce type
et qu'on se demande exactement comment
on va pouvoir assumer l'année financière
mais je crois que tout le monde est
pleinement conscient aussi bien la
présidence de l'université le rectorat
le ministère que les acteurs syndicaux
tout le monde est pleinement conscient
qu'on essaie tous d'aller dans le même
sens et que l'objectif c'est de faire
fonctionner une université de très haut
niveau dans un territoire en essayant de
trouver les solutions pour que le
financement soit pérenne et ne dépasse
pas ce qui nous a été alloué donc pour
le moment je je pense qu'on peut dire
que les discussions aussi bien
àintérieur de l'université qu'à
l'extérieur se sont passées plutôt en
bonne intelligence avec l'ensemble des
partenaires et que on peut rassurer les
gens il y a eu un effet de dramatisation
alors cette dramatisation elle est
normale parce que on découvre cette
situation financière qui est nouvelle
mais qui est nouvelle aussi parce que la
loi a changé il y a quelques années et
que à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin comme dans un tiers
globalement des universités françaises
on s'aperçoit que les les outils de
suivi financier et l'enveloppe
budgétaire donné par l'État ne sont pas
forcément à la hauteur des besoins mais
cette dramatisation qui a été très forte
au moment de l'hiver je crois qu'il a un
moment donné il faut en sortir pour dire
que voilà l'université continue à
fonctionner au quotidien les gens
travaillent il y a des projets il y a
des équipes qui investissent et euh tout
cela est quand même je dirais moins
dramatique que ça n'en a l'air parce que
c'est la première fois parce que notre
université sert un peu médiatiquement
d'exemples et parfois de Bou émissaire
qu'elle a peut-être suscité certaines
jalousies en étant à la fois jeune et
dynamique
mais que ce dynamisme il continue au
quotidien justement queles sont les les
les pistes que vous recherchez pour par
exemple je sais pas mutualiser des des
moyens alors par il y a quand même des
voilà l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin est là il y a un pôle SAET
qui est pas très loin il y a ors qui est
aussi pas très très loinon qu'il y a
plein de pôles qui pourrai se se réunir
travailler ensembleement déjà Rais tout
d'abord il faut savoir que toutes les
universités sont engagées dans un
processus de révision de leur formation
c'estàdire que le paysage universitaire
en France a plus changé depuis 10 ans
qu'il navait Chang depuis ma 68 donc on
a créé des nouvelles formations on a
créé ces Masters qui ont été des
diplômes extrêmement efficaces qui ont
bouleverser la donne de l'enseignement
supérieur mais on en a créé beaucoup
donc il faut aussi réfléchir à ce qu'on
fait avec ces masters aujourd'hui à
l'université de de Versailles
Saint-Quentin il y a plus de 120 Masters
euh donc notre travail peut-être il y en
a trop il faut en tout cas il faut euh
peutêtre a des doubl voilà il faut
réfléchir à la manière dont il s'agit de
de d'investir nos forces et euh nos
forces
comparativement à l'offre académique
puisquil y a on est dans une académie
qui va jusqu'à sergie à l'université de
sergie il y a CQ universités dans notre
académie et puis au plateau de saccly ce
grand projet de l'Université Paris sacly
qui qui se monre donc il y a une
réflexion mutisation donc a une
réflection qui est entamé sur la
mutualisation sur sur les doublons mais
qui est une réflexion je dirais qui
précède les difficultés financières qui
est une réflexion qui est normale
c'est-à-dire que à partir du moment où
on parle d'allocation de ressources
publiques il est normal de réfléchir à
la manière dont il est plus approprié
d'utiliser l'argent des gens de l'État
pour savoir comment former au mieux les
étudiants vous parliez de projets c'est
veut dire qu'il y a encore des il y a
encore des projets qui se mettent en
place à l'université il y a encore des
projet qui se mett en place et
heureusement je veux dire c'est c'est là
où je parlais tout à l'heure de de de
dramatisation c'est-à-dire que il y a
effectivement plusieurs tempos il y a
une difficulté financière sur un un
temps court qui est lié à ces
négociations autour du budget mais il y
a des projets sur un un un temps moyen
voire un temps long qui continue à
évoluer par exemple l'université de
versaill Saint-Quentin a été très
impliqué dans ce qu'on a appelé les
investissements d'avenir c'est-à-dire le
grand emprintt et et l'utilisation de de
ces ressources c'estàd que non seulement
il y a environ 1 milliard d'euros de ce
grand emprunt qui finance l'Université
Paris Saclay dont nous sommes partie
prenantes mais il y a toute une série
d'autres opérations dans lesquelles nous
nous sommes engagé autour de 2010 et ces
opérations aujourd'hui elles commencent
à porter leurs fruit c'est-à-dire que
nous avons
récemment célébrer la naissance de la
fondation de sciences du patrimoine qui
est une fondation partenariale financée
avec de l'argent du grand emprunt
par l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin l'université de sergie et
un certain nombre de grands partenaires
comme le Louvre la Bibliothèque
nationale de France le château de
versaill autour de la recherche sur le
patrimoine avec à la fois des sciences
exactes des sciences humaines et ça
c'est un projet qui un projet qui a été
lancé en 2010 mais mais qui est en train
de prendre de l'ampleur avec des
partenaires qui nous font confiance
deuxième exemple de ce type la semaine
dernière a été signée une convention
avec l'Agence nationale de la recherche
pour créer l'Institut de la transition
énergétique avec le min ministre des
Transports avec Louis Gallois qui est
commissaire général inv Vcom d'Ille
cette opération V voilà cette opération
vdcom si vous voulez c'est quand même un
budget
2014-2015 de 67 million d'euros avec
Citroën avec Renault avec PSA qui nous
font confiance je veux dire je crois que
pour tous ces acteurs nos problèmes sont
des problèmes conjoncturels qui sont
sérieux qu'on doit prendre au sérieux
enfin il faut rassurer les gens sur la
pérenité de notre dynamisme et de nos
projets donc en un mot votre état
d'esprit aujourd'hui
confiant ou vigilant vigilant parce que
on a des vrais on a des vrais défis mais
je crois qu'on a les forces pour les les
relever et en particulier dans le cadre
de l'Université Paris saclé bah merci en
tout cas ettian d' sur le plateau de TTV
fil pour nous apporter cet éclairage sur
l'état de l'Université de versaill
Saint-Quentin et on attend évidemment la
présentation du budget ce sera donc le
1er mars allez on va rester dans le
domaine de la recherche jacquesdric
rouau chercheur au CNRS est venu à la
Maison de l'Environnement à Man lesamo
animé une conférence autour de
l'évolution des espèces et Olivier Manco
Maniscalco pardon fait le point c'est
22000 jeunes c'est seulement 1 à 2 % du
getau une réflexion sur l'évolution des
espèces c'est ce que vient de proposer
la Maison de l'Environnement de Manil
etamo lors d'une rencontre avec Jacques
derric rouau chercheur au CNRS élément
majeur de notre biodiversité les espèces
animales ou végétales ont connu bien des
interprétations à travers les âge des
interprétations d'abord religieuses avec
le créationnisme où Dieu est à l'origine
de toute vie sur Terre
puis plus scientifique avec les théories
de Larque et Darwin qui constateent que
les espèces sont naturelles et qu'elles
évoluent certaines se modifient
tellement qu'elles deviennent même de
nouvelles espèces il y a le lézard des
murailles qui existe que tout le monde
connaît en Europe qui a été importé dans
une île de l'Adriatique suivie par des
généticiens et qui en quelques dizaines
d'années s'est mis à évoluer
d'unsectivore il est devenu herbivore sa
mâchoire est modifiée il y a des
modifications de sa taille de certains
de ses traits si bien qu'avec les
critères actuels avec lesquels on décrit
les lézards ce serait une nouvelle
espèce les espèces ne sont donc pas
immuables elles se transformment
s'adaptent à leur milieu et certaines
disparaissent c'est le principe selon
Darwin de la sélection naturelle sur
Terre on recense aujourd'hui près
d'un700000 espèces c'est beaucoup mais
selon les spécialistes il y en aurait
près de nous a permis de nous déplacer
sur le côté comme cousin les éilles ou
les Tau elle nous a pas accord le droit
de pouvoir tourner une t génétique qui
nous condamne à marcher toute notre vie
suivant la même ligne
[Musique]
droite voilà et pour finir en ce moment
ce sont les vacances et bien je vous
propose une balade en famille à la ferme
La Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet
isse les couleurs du cirque jusqu'au 2
mars un sujet signé Aurélia deissi et ho
dimoine pendant les vacances d'hiver
place au cirque à la ferme La Bergerie
Nationale à rambouiller propose tous les
après-midis différentes animations
autour des arts du cirque des parcours
d'acrobatie entre des bottes de paille
la fabrication de masqu à partir de
peinture au jaune d'œuf ou encore des
tours de magie où l'on transforme la
crème en beurre au programme également
des numéros de dressage pas de tigre ni
de lion mais des oies nos oies ont
l'avantage d'être élevés depuis tout
jeune parmi les chiens de bergers puis
que ce sont des oir qu'on utilise pour
entraîner les fiot et donc elles ont
l'habitude de se faire un petit peu
malmener par les chiens et donc les
enfants va dire que c'est un petit peu
les vacances pour elle et du coup il y a
aucun il y a aucun souci à ce niveaau
juste les
accompag on faisait une ronde et et on
devait mettre les Ies dans la ronde et
on se devait baisser et si quelqu'un
bougeait et
ben elle prend sa place et as après elle
s'enfuit on a levé nos bras et les oies
devaient passer en dessous mais il y en
a quelquesunes qui s'est
échappé en fin d'après-midi la visite
100 % nature se termine par la
découverte des soins aux animaux moutons
chèvres poules et vaches voilà de quoi
émerveiller nos petits apprentis
fermiers sur cette fite l' queu est
terminé merci de votre attention dans
quelques instants vous retrouvez kiosque
l'émission dédiée à la culture et au
loisir présenté par Aurélia de bici
bonne soirée à vous et à
[Musique]
bientôt